I have such a great documentary to
recommend to you that I watched the
other day this is a documentary called
first contact lost tribe of the Amazon
and it's a documentary it's not very
long it's about 50 minutes it's on
Netflix and it documents the first
contact with members of a previously
very isolated tribe on the bank of the
envira River in the village of sympathia
in Brazil and it includes an
anthropologist who who is really
extraordinary Jose Carlos marae's and
it's unbelievable the footage that you
see of literally the first contact with
a very very isolated tribe you also see
as they start to be able to communicate
with members of this tribe and translate
what was being said during that first
contact you realize the physical danger
in which these anthropologists
unknowingly were and maybe the most
interesting thing about it is after
first contact is made clothing is
provided to a to a tribe that mostly
would exist in the nude in the in the
Amazon ten months ten twelve months in
after first contact is made they're
asked about do you like clothes would
you want to maybe go back to before
contact where you now have these tools
you have clothes and in only 10 months
they say you know we're ashamed now to
walk around naked and it's so
interesting Pat to see how quickly you
see even something like getting used to
not being naked around people you're not
intimately familiar with that catches on
and becomes a really difficult idea to
separate yourself from you'd think after
years and years and years and years of
living naked 10 months of clothing
wouldn't fundamentally change your views
where you're just now ashamed to be
naked it did and it's just amazing to
see what happens when first contact is
made yeah could you imagine the culture
shock that goes on when you realize that
there's this whole outside world that's
more technologically advanced than you I
mean that's really quite stunning yeah
and that's another thing which is
fascinating they start to see blankets
right and and regular clothing and it's
it's just amazing to them
I could not recommend this more highly
you can of course find this and all of
my recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations this is again
called first contact Lost Tribe of the
Amazon it's on Netflix and it's
extraordinary and before we go to break
we have a great show today I will remind
you the 2017 David Pakman show calendars
are on sale the theme is comic book
coloring book and you can get your
calendar even for free with a membership
at david pakman.com slash calendar 17